respondent Amanda Walker reports it
doesn't look like much but a bridge just
beyond this checkpoint could provide a
pivotal moment for the people of
Venezuela US aid is on its way here to
Colombia getting it across the border is
a sensitive and secretive mission from
local farmland you can see a barrier in
the middle of the bridge recently put
there by President Maduro soldiers
Dianna's farm overlooks what could
become a flashpoint in this crisis what
do you think might happen on the bridge
[Music]
the people is gonna come and they're
gonna take it away do what they need to
do Colombia clearly wants this aid to
get through that's why later they allow
a small group of TV news cameras
including our own to seema Doros
makeshift blockade up close the
embattled leaders message is clear he
does not want international aid entering
his country Venezuela 'he's other
proclaimed leader Hwang Guido says it
needs to come now every day up to 30,000
people cross this other public bridge
from Venezuela into Colombia some are
leaving for good for most people it's a
daily grueling shopping trip for
necessities they can't get at home some
have walked miles in the baking heat
they're using what little money they
have four basic food pain relief nappies
and a few extras to sweeten an
incredibly tough existence Maria makes
the crossing every day with her five
children her main concern is the total
absence of medical facilities in
Venezuela there was nothing in there I
have to come here and get help my
daughter collapsed yesterday and I have
to come to the Red Cross in Colombia
she says her neighbor's son just died of
malnutrition like millions of Venezuelan
mothers she is doing everything she
possibly can
to protect her own people are also
selling whatever they can to scratch a
living desperate times call for
desperate measures this vendor is asking
women if they want to sell their hair
and if they're willing to sell this
length they could get up to $10 which in
this climate can make a big difference
everyone here has become adept at
finding things to make life bearable but
people need so much more than they can
get here they need proper aid Anna's
Whelan's have been carrying a heavy load
for years now this way of life isn't new
what has changed is a feeling of hope
help is at least on the horizon Amanda
Walker sky news cúcuta Columbia